FEMALE SPEAKER: Hello.
Thanks for coming today and
helping me welcome--
and I'm really hoping that
I get this right--
Dario Maestripieri to Google to
give us a talk on his new
book called "Games
Primates Play--
An Undercover Investigation of
the Evolution and Economics of
Human Behavior." He's a
professor from the University
of Chicago of five different
things that
he said not to mention.
But among them are comparative
human development and
evolutionary biology.
So he's an expert
in the field.
So if you could just join me
in giving him a round of
applause to say welcome, thanks
for coming to Google.
DARIO MAESTRIPIERI: It's
a pleasure to be here.
Can you hear me OK?
Great.
In 1964, two important events
occurred-- at least,
important to me.
First, I was born that year.
And second, in 1964 is the year
in which this book was
published, "Games People Play."
In this book, which
went on to become a huge
bestseller, sold over 5
million copies, the author, a
psychiatrist named Eric Berne,
argued that when people interact
with others in their
relationships, they do so
according to particular
patterns, particular rules
that typically result in
predictable outcomes.
And so he had an explanation
as to why these rules exist
and why we play the games
that we play in social
relationships.
Well, in the almost 50 years
since this book was published,
there's been a great deal of
progress in the science of
human relationships.
And I think there are
disciplines other than
psychology and psychiatry that
can help us understand why
people play the games that
they play in their
relationships.
There are at least these three
disciplines that I think make
an important contribution.
One is evolutionary biology.
And that's because I think that
human nature is very much
expressed in our social
behavior.
So I think that people have
biological predispositions to
act in certain ways towards
others, and that the genetic
basis and the neural,
physiological, cognitive,
behavioral mechanisms that
control social behavior evolve
by natural selection.
And natural selection tends to
produce behaviors that have
high benefit to cost ratios--
that is, behaviors that are
advantageous to the
individuals that exhibit these
behaviors and have
relatively low cost.
Another discipline that I think
is helpful to understand
human relationships is
behavioral economics.
Behavioral economists
assumed that
human behavior is rational--
that people behave in ways
that increase, again, the
benefit to cost ratio, that we
behave in ways that increase
the benefits to ourselves
at a small cost.
The difference in the approaches
that economists
take versus evolutionary
biologists is that the
economists assume that rational
behavior is the
product of a conscious choice,
that we think about the way we
want to behave and make these
conscious decisions.
Whereas biologists don't assume
that all behavior is
the product of conscious
choice.
The idea is natural selection
essentially takes care of the
rationality aspect
of our behavior.
So we behave in some occasions
unconsciously.
The third discipline that
I think can help us is
primatology, which is the study
of the behavior of other
non-human primate species.
And we need to know about this
because the same evolutionary
processes that shaped human
social behavior in some cases
have also shaped the behavior
of other primate species,
which means that there are
primate species in which
individuals play the
same games in their
relationships as we do.
So what I do in my book is to
offer an overview of human
social relationships, discuss
some of their problems, and
some of the solutions
to these problems.
So I began by discussing some
issues that arise when we
interact with strangers, for
example, in the elevator, or
lift, the way you call here.
Then, some issues relative to
interactions with family
members, and what happens when
we try to help our relatives
by behaving nepotistically.
The way we deal with friends and
foes-- for example, when
it comes to issues of dominance
and power or
cooperation and competition.
And finally, how we
deal with business
and romantic partners.
So some of the problems that
arise in the cooperative
relationships that we establish
with particular
individuals.
For example, I'll talk about
the commitment problem, and
the need in long-term
relationships to assess the
strength of the bond that we
have with our partner, and
also the issue of how
to find an ideal
partner to begin with.
And then I will conclude by
giving you some evolutionary
explanations as to why the
games that we play in our
relationships really were not
invented by human beings, but
can also be observed in
other animal species.
So let me begin by saying a
few things about why is it
that sometimes when we interact
with stranger in a
sort of harmless situation,
such as in the elevator,
sometimes we unconsciously
perceive that there is some
danger there, that there is some
risk in that situation.
I had the idea for the first
chapter of this book, and then
for the whole book, when I lived
in a high-rise building
in Chicago a few years ago, the
transportation building.
I lived in an apartment
on the 22nd floor.
So every morning, I took the
lift to go down, and then to
go up at the end of the day.
And every day, almost
inevitably, I met somebody new
that I didn't know, because
there's so many apartments in
this building.
And as you all know because you
found yourself millions of
times in this situation,
sometimes, whether you're
alone with a strange or with
multiple people, you do
everything you possibly can to
avoid making direct eye-to-eye
contact, to behave in ways
that might be annoying to
others, to make loud noises.
So you'll stare at the floor
or the ceiling or you will
check your watch even though
you already know
what time it is.
Sometimes you'll press a floor
button that's already been
pressed but you go ahead
and do it anyway.
Essentially, you don't want to
acknowledge the presence of
the other individual.
You're a little uncomfortable
about this.
So why is it that this
situation occurs?
Why is it that we have to face
these dilemmas in the elevator
between making or not making
eye contact, smiling or not
smiling, talking or not talking,
pressing or not
pressing a button that's already
been pressed, and what
to do, how not to reveal the
little tension that sometimes
we reveal through our
self-directed behavior-- we
scratch our heads a little
bit when we're nervous.
So why is it that we're
uncomfortable being in a
restricted space with
a stranger?
This is not a hot topic for
research by any stretch of the
imagination these days.
But in the 1960s, it was.
And an anthropologist named
Edward T. Hall wrote a book
called "The Hidden Dimension,"
in which he argued that people
have a personal space that is
analogous to an invisible
bubble that we carry around
ourselves everywhere we go,
and that we respond
to an invasion of
this personal space.
So when somebody gets
too close to
us, then we get defensive.
And he drew an analogy between
people's personal space and
animals' territories.
So the idea is that when an
animal who has a territory,
this territory is invaded by a
stranger, the animal would
respond aggressively or try
to defend the territory.
And so that was the explanation,
which I never
really found very convincing,
first of all, because I don't
think it's a real explanation.
It doesn't explain why there is
this bubble and why is that
we don't like having
this bubble
invaded by someone else.
It's simply a description of
what happens, but without
really explaining why
this happens.
So I have a different
explanation, and it's
illustrated here by
these two slides.
I don't know if some of you
remember this old movie from
the '80s directed by Brian De
Palma called "Dressed to
Kill," but in one of the most
famous scenes of the movie, a
character played by actress
Angie Dickinson is in the
elevator going up to
the seventh floor.
And the elevator door opens and
the killer, who's dressed
like a woman, wearing a wig and
sunglasses, slashes the
woman's face with
a razor blade.
And so there are a lot of scenes
in horror movies in
which people are murdered
in elevators.
I think it's the second most
common place for murders to
occur after the shower,
if you think about it.
So that's another cartoon that
sort of illustrates some of
the unconscious fears that we
might have if we ride in
elevators with strangers.
So I think that the real reason
why we act the way we
do is not that we're concerned
about our bubble being
invaded, but that our mind
unconsciously registers that
there is a risk of aggression,
being so close to a stranger
in a situation where there's
no opportunity to escape if
there is a fight.
So for example, we don't make
eye contact, because in all
primate species, direct
eye contact is
perceived as a threat.
So we consciously know this,
that if we stare at somebody
in their eyes, they might
not like that.
And they might think that
we want to pick
a fight with them.
And so we avoid that.
So if we put two monkeys in a
cage who have not met before,
you see exactly the
same dynamics.
You see the same elevator
behaviors.
You see the same efforts to
try and act indifferent.
Then there's things that
are unique to humans.
So one thing that I've noticed
on my many elevator rides in
Chicago is that sometimes I
re-press a floor button, and
then a stranger walks into the
elevator and presses this
button again.
Why?
Is it that the person did not
see that the button was
already lit?
That was not the case, because
I notice that they actually
look at the panel, they realize
the button is already
lit, but they press it again.
Why?
Again, I think this has to do
with trying not to acknowledge
the presence of the
other person.
So if you see the button has
already been pressed, you're
acknowledging there's somebody
there, he's pressed the
button, happens to be going
to the same floor as I am.
So there's something
that links us.
We even share goals.
Animal researchers like to think
that sharing of goals is
a very important aspect of our
lives and behavior, something
that might be unique
to humans.
So it might be the hallmark
of personhood.
And so it's just easier, if
you have to deal with a
potentially dangerous stranger,
not to acknowledge
that this person is there, that
it's a real person has
goals, and that you connect
in some way.
So it's just easier just to
ignore and just press the
button again.
And sometimes this happens.
So I mentioned that you can put
two monkeys in a cage and
observe some of the
same behavior.
And that's what I did when I
was a college student many
years ago at the University
of Rome in Italy.
My very first experiment I
worked with nonhuman primates
was to put two monkeys
an a cage.
I had many different
combinations of individuals,
some of which had met before,
they were housed in the same
group, and others instead
who had not met before.
So I let them be together in
this cage for an hour, I
recorded their behavior, and
I observed what happened.
So in the pairs of monkeys that
had met before, they knew
each other, what happened was
that these monkeys very
quickly started grooming
each other.
So they spent almost the entire
hour grooming each
other, which is an affiliative
behavior, it reduces tension.
So essentially, the monkeys
tried to deal with the
awkwardness of the situation by
engaging in this behavior.
The pairs of monkeys in which
there was no previous
familiarity, initially they
showed a lot of elevator
behaviors, a lot of anxiety, a
lot of avoiding eye contact.
And then, two different
subgroups of pairs emerged.
There was one subgroup of pairs
in which each monkey of
the pair requested to be groomed
by the other monkey.
And monkeys do this by showing
the part of the body that they
want to have groomed-- for
example, an arm or the back or
their body.
But typically, the other
monkey would not start
grooming, instead would respond
to this request with
another request.
So he said, no, I'm
not grooming you.
You groom me.
And they kept on rejecting these
advances from the other.
And so there was very little
grooming going on the whole
hour because they kept on asking
each other to groom and
kept on saying no, you do it.
You're turn.
Whereas in other pairs, grooming
started very late in
the session.
And eventually, when it started,
essentially one of
the two monkeys did
all the work.
Those monkeys seemed very
concerned about the situation
and essentially accepted
to do most of the work.
So initially, I couldn't make
any sense of these differences
in behavior.
And then finally, I realized
that the monkeys were playing
a game, which in economics and
game theory is called the
prisoner's dilemma, which is
a way in which cooperative
interactions may or may not
occur when two individuals are
put together in a situation
like this.
And I'm sure you're all familiar
with this model, but
for those of you who are not,
so it's a hypothetical
situation in which two men are
accused of the same crime and
they are interrogated by the
police independently in
separate rooms, where they
cannot communicate.
And each person has
two options.
They can either confess--
they can say, I did it.I
committed the crime.
This is called the cooperate
move Or they can accuse the
other, which is called
the defect.
And the payoffs in this game are
the convictions that they
get depending on what they do.
So the number of years of prison
sentence that they get.
So if they both defect, they
both get three years.
If they both cooperate, they
both get one year in jail.
But what's interesting is what
happens if one person
cooperates and the
other defects.
So the person who defects
actually walks away with no
sentence at all, whereas the one
who cooperates gets a very
heavy sentence, five
years in jail.
So as you can see from this
matrix, if you take the
perspective of player one,
you see that it's always
advantageous to defect not
knowing what the other person
will do, because if you defect
and the other cooperates, you
get zero years versus
one year, so
it's better to defect.
And if you defect and the other
defects, you get three
years versus five.
So not knowing what the other
will do, if you have certainty
that the other will cooperate,
you might choose to cooperate.
But not knowing, it always
pays to defect.
This is what you do if
you interact with a
stranger only once.
But if interactions with the
same individuals are repeated,
then the best strategy's called
tit for tat, which is
that you simply do what the
other person has done in the
previous move.
So if the other partner has
cooperated in the previous
move, you cooperate.
If they defected, you defect.
And sort of keep track of
the previous moves.
So these are some of the
problems that arise in
interaction with strangers.
The main problem is that you
don't know what the stranger's
intentions are.
You don't know whether they're
friendly or hostile.
The situation gets more
complicated if this encounter
with a stranger occurs in a
restricted space, and where
the cost of aggression
will be high.
If two monkeys get into a fight
in a small cage, there's
a good chance they'll get
seriously injured.
The solution to this problem is
to develop these protective
behavioral strategies.
So when cooperation is possible,
the solution to the
problem depends on whether
you're interacting with the
other individual only once,
in which case you
tend to behave selfishly.
If you interact repeatedly,
instead, tit for tat
is the way to go.
Now, these sorts of problems do
not occur when you interact
with people you know very well,
and especially with
family members, because you have
a shared interest with
these people.
So there's all kinds of
different problems that arise
with family members.
And one general problem with
relatives is that you
have to help them.
Especially if you have children,
you want your
children to be successful
in life.
And so sometimes you end up
behaving nepotistically.
What is nepotism?
Nepotism is widespread
in nature.
Biologists are very
familiar with it.
And to a biologist, nepotism
simply means to favor your
relative members at the expense
of non-relatives.
There is no animal species on
this planet where individuals
favor non-relatives at the
expense of family members.
So nepotism is a human
phenomenon.
This is a cartoon that sort of
illustrates the issues, where
somebody's looking for a job and
the guy says, you've got a
great CV but you're not quite
what we look for, because they
look for the sons
of the owner.
And so there's a photo with
all the same face.
That's what they're
looking for.
So in preparing for writing for
this book, I came across
an interesting book written by
Adam Bellow, who happens to be
the son of former University of
Chicago English professor
Saul Bellow, who was also
a Nobel Prize winner for
literature.
So his son Adam wrote a book
called "In Praise of
Nepotism," in which he made some
interesting claims, which
I try to summarize in the slide,
just to give you a gist
of what he says about
nepotism.
So let me read it very
quickly to you.
He says, "Nepotism
is something we
can hardly do without.
For one thing, nepotistic
concern for the welfare of
children is the engine of
the capitalist system.
Take that away and you destroy
the main incentives for
innovation and the creation
of wealth.
For another, meritocracy
unleavened by
personal ties is inhumane.
Finally, on the individual
level, nepotism is a
profoundly moral relationship,
one that transmits social and
cultural values and forms a
healthy bond between the
generations.
In short, nepotism works, it
feels good, it is generally
the right thing to do.
It has its origins in nature,
has played a vital role in
human social life, and boasts
a record of impressive
contributions to the progress
of civilization."
So that's an interesting
position to take.
Obviously, I agree with some
of the statements here.
I agree that nepotism
has its origins in
nature, as I explained.
But there is a big difference
between nepotism in animals
and nepotism in humans.
So I wrote an article that was
published in a magazine in
which I elaborate on
this argument.
And one of my chapters in
the book is about this.
But just to make a long story
short, the difference between
nepotism in animals and in
humans is that when animals
behave nepotistically to help
their family members, they
don't break any rules,
because there are no
rules in animal societies.
There's no moral rules, there's
no societal rules,
cultural norms, there's
no laws.
There's no right or wrong.
There is no morality.
Animals are amoral.
Whereas in humans, the problem
with nepotism is not that we
help our relatives, but
it's how we help them.
And almost inevitably, when we
help relatives, we end up
breaking some rules.
We end up breaking
some moral code.
We end up breaking some laws,
some cultural norms, and in
some cases, we end up
committing crimes.
So there are people--
dictators, for example-- who
will murder others in the
process of helping their
family members.
So I sort of provide a very
alternative view of the
benefits and the problems with
nepotism in human societies
versus in animals.
Now let me switch gears a little
bit right now and talk
about how we deal with friends
and foes with regard to issues
of dominance and power,
something that everybody has
some interest in, I believe.
So again, when I was writing
this book, one day, I happened
to think about the fact that
human beings have evolved
essentially to interact face
to face with others.
For much of our evolutionary
history, we had relationships
with people that we could see
directly, that we could hear,
and that we could touch.
But these days, instead we
maintain social relationships
over email or over Facebook
or Google+, or whatever.
So we maintain a relationship
with people that we can't see.
So I wondered if this way of
maintaining relationships has
altered some fundamental
way the way we have our
relationships.
And then I started thinking
about the dynamics, for
example, in which emails are
exchanged between people.
I realized that no, even though
we use email, there's
still some dynamics in these
email exchanges that remind us
of the way we used to deal with
relationships, and also
the way other primates
deal with it.
For example, if you think about
it, the way two people
exchange email messages with
one another, the way it
happens is that typically there
is an email conversation
with the messages going back
and forth which begins when
one person sends an email to
another one, typically asking
some questions or sharing some
information, making some requests.
The receiver of the email thinks
about it then replies
after a while, answering
the questions.
And the first person writes
another email.
There's some interval of time
between the email and the
response, so the exchange goes
back and forth for a while.
And then at some point,
somebody doesn't reply
anymore, and that ends
the conversation.
And then maybe there'll be
another conversation about a
few days later or months
or whatever.
Well, if you think about it,
who starts the conversation
exchange, how long it takes to
reply, how long or short the
replies are and who ends
the conversation.
In my view, these are not
random phenomena.
There is a logic to it.
And I think the logic has to do
with differences in status
between the two individuals.
In every relationship, there
is an individual who's
dominant, an individual
who's subordinate--
one of higher status and
one of lower status.
And what this means is that
there are different
benefits and costs.
So the person of lower status
has more to gain from the
interaction, and so is more
willing to invest.
The other one has less interest
in investing.
To illustrate this point, let
me give you an example, a
hypothetical email exchange
between, say, a graduate
student named Jessica and her
advisor, Professor Smith.
They're having an email exchange
which begins when
Jessica writes a long,
unsolicited email to Professor
Smith in which she asks a lot of
questions and requests some
information.
Professor Smith sees the email,
he lets it sit for a
while, and then sends a short
reply answering all the
questions, providing
all the information
that Jessica requested.
Obviously, Jessica's very
encouraged by the fact that
she got the reply
from her boss.
And so immediately, she sends an
even longer email with more
questions, more requests
for information.
This time, Professor Smith waits
a little bit longer.
He waits until the next day,
and then responds with an
email that is a little bit
shorter than the first one.
But Jessica then writes
back and writes two
or three more emails.
Professor Smith replies later
and later, and with
increasingly short messages,
until after email number five
from Jessica, Professor Smith
lets this email sit
indefinitely in his mailbox
and that's the end of the
conversation.
If I described the way two
chimpanzees groom each other,
you'll see that there's some
interesting similarities in
the dynamic.
So the way grooming is
exchanged between two
chimpanzees is that the
subordinate individual
approaches the dominant and
starts grooming, does so for a
very long time, then stops
and asks for the
dominant to groom back.
The dominant thinks about it for
a while, then grooms the
subordinate, but for a very
short bout, and then stops and
says, now, your turn again.
And so the subordinate grooms
for a very long time again,
then stops and asks the
dominant to reply.
The dominant this time waits
even longer, and his reply is
even shorter, and the grooming
goes back and forth until the
dominant simply gets
up and walks away.
And that's the end of
the email exchange.
So there's an interesting
similarity.
So nothing has changed
completely because of email as
a medium for communication.
But let me tell you about what
dominance is and why we should
care about it.
So I'll use a simple example
to illustrate a game theory
approach to dominance.
Let's imagine that one day Yogi
Bear and Boo Boo Bear
meet in the middle of a forest
and find an apple.
They're both hungry, they both
want the apple, the apple
cannot be shared.
And so each bear has
two options.
They can either threaten the
other to escalate a fight to
get the apple--
that's called the hawk move--
or they can let the other
bear get the apple.
That's called the dove.
Essentially, you behave
submissively.
In this case, just to keep
things simple, let's assume
that if they have a fight,
each has a 50% chance of
winning the fight.
In reality, the contests are
never symmetrical like this.
But in this situation, there are
three possible outcomes,
three possible situations; one
in which both bears play hawk,
so there's a fight over the
apple; one in which they both
play dove, so there's
negotiation over who gets the
apple; and the third situation
is one in which one plays hawk
and the other one plays dove.
That's dominance.
So dominance is a situation in
which a disagreement or a
conflict of interest is resolved
by one individual
acting aggressively,
threatening, to escalate a
fight and the other one say,
OK, you can do it.
You can have your way.
Why does dominance occur?
Why does dominance exist?
Because it would be very
expensive in terms of energy
and time, and counterproductive
in many way,
to resolve all disagreements
through fighting or
negotiation.
Imagine how many times, those
of you who are married, you
disagree with your spouse over
what food you're going to eat
at dinner or what TV channel
you're going to watch every
evening if you have to fight
over every disagreement, or if
you have to negotiate over who
decides this and that.
I think that this would be
a huge strain on your
relationship, with a lot of
negative consequences.
And that's why dominance
exists.
If there's one person who calls
the shots all the time,
essentially this makes things
easier, quicker, and saves
everybody a lot of stress.
So dominance is a ubiquitous
phenomenon, a universal
aspect, I think, of all
human relationships.
There's dominance between
parents and children.
siblings.
Children fight to establish
dominance with their peers as
early as two years of age.
There's studies of kids on
playgrounds where they
establish dominance
with each other.
I think there is dominance
in romantic relationship.
You can ask yourself whether
you or your partner is more
dominant in your relationship,
who makes the decisions.
And obviously, there is
dominance in the workplace.
There's dominance between
employers and employees.
And I want to talk a little
bit more about
this type of dominance.
So imagine a company
such as this one.
Every individual, every
employee, has a dominance
relationship with every
other employee.
The result of this is a
dominance hierarchy that looks
a little bit like this.
So there is somebody at the
top and other people of
various levels, various
steps of the ladder.
So suppose that you're
a new employee.
You just joined this company.
Typically, you find yourself
sort of towards the bottom.
But you're ambitious.
You want to climb the ladder.
So how do you do it?
How do you climb the ladder
in the workplace?
It turns out that there's
different ways to do it--
different strategies.
So I talk about these strategies
and illustrate them
with a hypothetical character.
So the first strategy is
illustrated by a person I call
the good citizen.
So this is a new employee who
joins the company and is very
friendly, very submissive, says
yes to all requests for
work, attends all the business
meetings, never complaints
about anything, never rocks
the boat, never asks for a
salary raise or promotion--
essentially, the strategy is
to be a good citizen and to
wait passively for things just
to take their course.
And to hope that you will slowly
and gradually increase
in rank through a seniority
system where eventually you
are rewarded for your good
behavior by your bosses.
Some people use this strategy
and it may work, but if you
happen to be the ambitious
type who wants to climb
quickly and maybe get at the top
sometime soon, I would not
recommend this strategy.
At some point, you need to rock
the boat if you want to
get up there.
So then there's a second
strategy, illustrated by this
individual I call
the young Turk.
So this is a guy or a woman who
I said has no patience,
has no interest in playing
the good citizen.
He wants to get up and
get there fast.
And so he will challenge
the person on the top
almost on day one.
So imagine that you're a
new employee at Google.
The first day you join the
company, in a business
meeting, you say, I
have issues with
the CEO of this company.
I have proof that he's, I don't
know, embezzled money,
whatever, and I can
be a better boss.
And see how that goes, whether
this strategy works.
Essentially, it's
a coup d'etat.
It may or may not work,
depending on the
circumstances.
People who attempt this
typically are very
self-confident, very cocky.
They obviously think
they have reasons
why this might succeed.
And it might under certain
circumstances.
Then there's a third strategy,
illustrated by a character I
call the Machiavellian
strategist.
So this new employee is somebody
who initially acts
very nice to everybody, very
friendly, will establish
relationships with every other
employee in the company, will
take everybody out to lunch the
first month, but in the
meantime, will gather
information about the dynamic
of power within the company.
So this person finds out who
has power and who doesn't,
who's going up and who's going
down on the hierarchy, who is
friends with whom, who's enemies
with whom, who's
sleeping with whom--
essentially, identifies a few
key players and establishes
alliances with these
key players.
And then after a while, when the
good opportunity presents
itself, using the base of
support that this person has
built, eventually this person
will challenge the person at
the top and try to
take their place.
So the interesting thing about
these strategies is that if
you study a particular kind
of monkeys, called macaque
monkeys, which I study.
These are Asian monkeys that
live in large groups.
They have dominance
hierarchies,
just like our own.
If you study males in the
process of migrating to a new
group-- so males leave the group
in which they're born
and join a new group when they
reach puberty, at about four
or five years of age.
So they join this new group
where they don't know anybody,
there's a well-established
dominance ladder, and
obviously, these males would
like to get to the top and be
the alpha male because there's
all kinds of benefits
associated with that.
Well, they can do one
of three things.
We happen to be equivalent
to what you
could do in a company.
So you can act as a good
citizen, what we call the
"unobtrusive immigrant"--
behave submissively, start at
the bottom of the hierarchy,
and hope that gradually and
slowly, you will increase in
rank, essentially to a seniority
system, because the
older, more senior, more
dominant people eventually
will die or get sick or leave
the company, and you will
essentially be rewarded
for your patience
and your good behavior.
Then there is the "challenge
immigrant," the guy who joins
the group and on day one picks
a fight with the alpha male,
challenges the alpha male--they
have a big fight.
This is a young male,
typically, a very
self-confident, strong, high
testosterone, risk taker.
In some cases, this
is successful.
So he will defeat the alpha
male in a fight and will
become alpha in one day.
And then there's the "challenger
resident"--
somebody who's a little more
Machiavellian, will join the
group, behave submissively
initially, establish
relationships, gather
information, make alliances,
and then one day, maybe a year
later, launch the challenge.
So things are very similar.
So the question is, why is it
that we see these three
different strategies?
Why do they exist, and what's
the best strategy for you in
whatever situation you
find yourself to be.
So there's theories in biology,
which also I use some
principle from economics, that
essentially tell you these
strategies exist and there's
pros and cons depending on the
structure of power within
the organization.
So in the figures there, that's
the power ladder.
And it makes a difference how
this ladder is positioned,
whether it's positioned sort of
against the wall sort of in
a gentle slope like that, almost
horizontal, or whether
it's almost vertical
like that, it's on
a very steep slope.
In the first case, essentially,
you find yourself
in a large organization where
this system of power is pretty
egalitarian.
Power is distributed among
different people, not just in
the hands of one person at the
top, and there's a high degree
of social inertia.
So in this situation, the
benefits of being right at the
top are relatively low because,
as I said, power is
distributed.
It's not all in the hands
of one person.
And the cost of attaining top
rank through a direct
challenge--
for example, of your CEO--
are potentially high because the
CEO has a lot of support.
There's a lot of inertia.
So the chance that you might
succeed in that are very low.
So I recommend the "good
citizen," or, if you're a
monkey, the "unobtrusive
immigrant" strategy.
But if you find yourself in a
different situation in which
there is a steeper
slope ladder--
the system is more despotic, the
power is concentrated in
the hands of one person or
a couple of people--
then the benefits of top rank
are very high, because it
makes a big difference
being at the top.
So there's high stakes in
challenging the leader.
The cost of a direct challenge
might vary.
For example, in a small group
where the leader does not have
a strong base of support, it
pays to try an immediate
challenge because you have
higher chances of succeeding.
So you might want to try
the "young Turk" or the
"challenging immigrant"
strategy.
Whereas in the larger group,
the cost is higher.
So in both cases, the benefits
are very high because there's
a lot at stake.
But in the second case, the
costs are higher, and so it
pays to wait a while, to gather
information, to build
alliances, and then
to challenge.
So you want to be a
Machiavellian strategist in
this situation.
So these are some of the things
that we can learn from
evolutionary biology, from
economics, and from studying
other primate species.
There's more we can learn
about relationships with
friends and foes when it comes
to issues of cooperation and
competition.
To illustrate this, I brought
a slide of my research
institute at the University
of Chicago.
It's called the
Biopsychological Science Building.
And that's a colleague of
mine, Dr. Steve Shevell.
He's a psychologist.
He loves espresso, as I'm
sure many of you do.
So he bought, years ago, a very
fancy espresso machine,
and runs an espresso club, which
means that people go
there in the morning and
make their own coffee.
And then they mark a paper sheet
on the wall reporting,
essentially, how many cups of
coffee they've had that day.
At the end of the month,
you count, and
people pay their bills.
So nobody checks.
Nobody monitors.
Somebody in the UK, at the
University of Newcastle, had a
similar system where people
would make themselves coffee
and tea and then the put coins
in a box to pay for their
coffee and tea.
So this psychologist did an
experiment where on a certain
week, he would put, or she put,
an image of flowers on
the file cabinet right above
the coffee maker.
And on the following
week, there'd be an
image of two eyes.
And then these images
alternated.
So one week there were
flowers, one
week there were eyes.
And then they checked and
recorded how many coins people
put in the box.
So you can see from that graph,
every week there were
eyes, people paid a lot
more for their coffee
and for their tea.
So why is that?
Is that that people think that
somebody's watching, there's
somebody hidden in the
cup over there
monitoring what they do?
No, obviously not.
But unconsciously, every time
we see eyes, we think that
there's some perception that
we're being watched.
And when people perceive that
they're being watched, there's
a lot of studies that show
that they tend to be more
honest, more cooperative,
more generous.
So there's studies showing, for
example, that if you take
a computerized test with another
person in which you
can choose whether or not to
cooperate and the image on the
desktop, the background image,
has a pair of eyes like this--
and they don't even need
to look that human--
so people tend to cooperate
more, tend to be more generous
and to be nicer if there's a
desktop image like this.
And there's even a study that
showed a robot, this robot
built at MIT called Kismet,
that does not look like a
human being at all, but
has big, big eyes.
And so when people see the
picture of the robot, they so,
oh, somebody's watching me.
And so, for example, studies
have shown that people are
more likely to cooperate in a
prisoner's dilemma game or to
contribute to the pool in public
goods game-- these are
experiments that economists
use--
if their identity's revealed
than if they play anonymously.
And also, it's well known that
people are more likely to
donate money to charities if the
identity's revealed and if
the amount of their contribution
is acknowledged.
So why this happens is that if
you're being watched, or if
you think you're being watched,
unconsciously, there
is a potential gain from
behaving yourself.
So you establish a good
reputation, which could mean
good business in the future.
So people take notice
of who acts
cooperatively and who doesn't.
And if you don't behave yourself
while you're being
watched, you might gain
a bad reputation.
And people sometimes go a great
length, and they're
willing to invest a significant
amount of money,
to give somebody a
bad reputation.
In this case, this was an angry
woman whose husband
probably cheated on her.
And she obviously spent a lot of
money to put this billboard
out there essentially giving her
husband a bad reputation
and trying to prevent him from
finding mates in the future.
So when you're in the
spotlight, it pays to cooperate.
So if you're being watched,
the reputation benefits of
cooperation are high.
The costs of cheating
are high too.
But what if you know for a fact
that you're not being
watched, and nobody's
watching?
What if you're operating in
conditions of anonymity or in
the darkness?
In that case, the benefits of
being competitive might be
high, and the costs are low
because you think, or you
know, that you're not
going to get caught.
So to illustrate that, I discuss
in my book the New
York City power blackout
of 1977.
So one day that year, a large
part of the city was left in
the darkness for several hours
due to a lightning strike.
And that night, hundreds
of people were
mugged, raped, or murdered.
Over 1,500 stores were looted.
More than 500 police officers
were injured.
More than 4,000 people
were arrested.
And many more probably committed
crimes that were not
arrested, were not caught.
And most of these people had no
previous criminal record,
so it's not like all the career
criminals committed
crimes and no one else did.
This was the large mass
arrest in the
history of New York City.
There is a proverb in Italy that
goes something like this,
[SPEAKING ITALIAN], which means
opportunity turns men
into a thief.
What does that mean?
What's a good opportunity
for stealing?
It's one in which the benefits
are high and
the costs are low.
If you know, or think, you're
not going to get caught,
that's a good opportunity
to be a thief.
And so if you believe in this
proverb, you can think that
essentially there are two
different ideas, or different
views, as to why there's police
officers out there
patrolling the streets.
Some people think that the world
is divided into good
people who never do anything
wrong and bad people.
And the police officer out
there are essentially
protecting the good people
from the bad people.
But there's another view,
which is that the police
officers are out there not to
protect the good people from
the bad apples, but essentially,
to discourage
everyone from committing crimes,
and to make sure that
they're punished
if they do so.
So the bottom line is that
people are sensitive in these
changes in benefit
to cost ratios.
And whenever the benefits of
behaving selfishly are high
and the costs are low because
you don't get caught, then
people have a tendency to behave
in a more competitive,
more selfish way.
There's another example I use
in my book of how anonymity
may promote competitive
impulses.
And that is the way the peer
review process works in
academia, the fact that
professors and researchers
review each other's papers
and grant applications.
And in most cases, they
do this anonymously.
So when you review somebody's
paper, you know the author of
the paper, but they don't
know your identity.
So peer review is anonymous,
in general, to protect
reviewers from the wrath
of rejected authors.
So the idea is that if you
know the identity of the
person who rejected your grant
application or your paper,
you're going to try
and retaliate.
That this occurs, there
is evidence of that.
This is a well-known episode.
In February, 2010, a biology
professor in Alabama who was
denied tenure in her department
by her colleagues
shot to death three of them
in a faculty meeting.
She went there with a rifle
and killed them all.
So you can be angry if
you get rejected.
But the question is, in this
system, who protects authors
from the anonymous reviewers?
So the anonymous reviewers are
in a position in which they
can be competitive with authors
and get away with it
because their identity
is unknown.
Does this really happen, or is
this just the product of my
paranoid imagination?
It does happen.
There are studies of the
anonymous peer review system
that shows that manuscripts are
more likely to be accepted
when authors request that
competing researchers be
excluded as reviewers.
So if you know who the potential
bad guys are and you
tell them, I don't want these
people to review my stuff,
there's a better chance that
your paper will be accepted.
Also, there's studies that have
compared single blind
reviews, in which the author
is known and the reviewer's
anonymous, and double blind
reviews, in which both author
and reviewer are anonymous.
It turns out that reviewers are
more likely to recommend
rejection of authors who are
women, who are colleagues from
a competing institution, or
citizens of another country in
single blind and double
blind reviews.
So when they know the identity
of the author, there's all
kinds of biases against
particular groups of people
that are expressed in
this situation.
And I think anonymity plays
a role in this.
There's also competition
between age cohorts.
I was once told by an NIH grant
officer that senior
scientists sometimes
kill they're young.
They're not so nice
to younger people.
There's competition between
different age groups.
And there's also some sort of
tribal competition between
groups of researchers that work
with different topics and
different questions.
So I'm a monkey researcher.
I work with monkeys.
When I apply for grants, I'm
terrified that my grant
application might be reviewed by
people who work with rats,
because the rat people want to
exterminate all the monkey
people because they think that
our animals are cooler than
theirs and so they want to
reject our application.
So there is some of this
stuff going on.
The bottom line is that the
darkness, unfortunately,
conditions of anonymity, tend
to favor competition because
the reputation benefits of
cooperation are low.
If you behave yourself, you
don't get credit because your
identity is not known.
Well, the costs of cheating are
low too, because you don't
get caught.
So these are some issues
you need to consider.
Let me say a little bit more
about some of the issues that
arise in cooperative
relationships with business or
romantic partners.
So typically, when you
establish a long-term
relationship in which there's
some degree of cooperation,
whether it's business or
romantic, like marriage, at
the beginning, typically, the
benefits of the relationships
are greater than the costs
for both individuals.
Otherwise, why would you start
up that relationship, right?
Well, what happens
with time is that
circumstances often change.
And this benefit to cost ratio
might change for one of the
two individuals, so that at some
point, the cost of being
in that relationship become
greater than the benefits.
So that individual for whom this
happens is tempted then
either to end the relationship
or to start cheating.
So economists describe this
as the commitment problem.
How do you keep a cooperative
relationship together?
And there's reasons to
keep it together.
For example, if it's a marriage,
there might be
children involved.
If it's a company, there might
be other employees that might
suffer from the break-up
and stuff like that.
So how do you keep
it together?
How do you know that your
partner is committed?
How do you maintain this
commitment in spite of these
changes in benefit
to cost ratios?
Because these changes
will happen.
And an American economist named
Bob Frank a few years
ago published a book called
passions within reason, in
which he advanced this theory
about the evolution of
romantic love.
He argued that romantic love
evolved to provide a solution
to the commitment problem
in romantic cooperative
relationships.
In other words, for two people
to stay together, he argued,
at some point, rational
decisions don't matter
anymore, because these benefit
to cost ratio will change.
So you need some irrational
feeling, you need some
irrational force that's going
to make you stick to your
partner in the relationship,
regardless of the losses that
you have and whatever
changes in these
cost to benefit ratios.
So here's this idea.
So that's why we fall in love,
to make sure we maintain
commitment in spite of
cost and benefits.
Is this really true?
Is this really true that this
view of love explains our
knowledge of this phenomenon
in every situation?
How about this?
Does this view of love as a
solution to the commitment
problem explain Cyrano
de Bergerac?
You know the story
of this play.
Cyrano is in love with
a woman who does not
reciprocate his love.
In fact, she doesn't even know
that he's in love with her.
But he's in love with
her for years.
And so obviously, love here
is not about maintaining
commitment.
It's not about maintaining the
relationship, because they
don't even have a
relationship.
So an important part of love
is really the longing for a
relationship.
You want to be with somebody.
And whether you're actually with
this person or not, it
doesn't really change the fact
that you love this person.
So I think that the economist
theory does not apply to all
situations in which
love occurs.
And there's other issues that
I discuss in my book.
So here's a different theory
that I consider as to why love
has evolved, why is it that
people fall in love, which I
think is pretty unique to
the species, actually.
There's no equivalent of
romantic love in others.
To understand the function of
love, I think you have to
think about the function
of emotions.
Love is an emotion.
And the function of emotions
in general are to energize
motivation.
So if you feel a strong positive
or negative emotion,
that's going to make you want
to do something, or make you
want to avoid something a lot
more than if this emotion was
not present.
So emotions energize
motivation.
And so one possibility is that
love evolved essentially to
motivate men and women to get
together, to reproduce, and
stay together at least as long
as it takes to raise one or
more children to make sure
that they survive.
So you're all familiar with this
old movie "The Seven Year
Itch." The title comes from some
divorce data back in the
'70s suggesting that most
couples who divorce do so
after seven years.
Most recent data suggests that
it's actually four years.
And there's interesting
research done by
anthropologists to suggest
that in non-industrial
societies, typically a woman has
a child every four years.
So women breast feed their
children for four years.
And so after four years, when
the child is actually--
has a pretty good chance that
he will survive or she will
survive, because the first
couple of years are really
risky in terms of infant
survival, then that woman will
move on and have another child
or maybe split up.
So the idea is that it takes two
parents to raise a child
successfully.
And so when two people get
together and stay together--
if love didn't exist, if there
was only sex, I think people
would still have sex, but I
don't think that they would
spend much time together.
So the best illustration of this
principle that love is an
energizer--
I found this monologue from one
of my favorite radio show
hosts, Joe Frank.
He's based in Los Angeles,
has a radio show.
This is taken from his "Love
Prisoner" monologue.
You can read it for yourself.
It sort of really speaks to this
notion that when you fall
in love, it generates so much
energy, you're willing to do
all kinds of things.
And that motivates you to
establish and maintain this
relationship.
So what about the commitment
problem?
If love is not the solution to
the commitment problem, how do
we solve the commitment
problem?
Well, here's how baboons have
come up with a solution to the
commitment problems In baboons,
two males form a
political alliance where they
help each other in fights.
So when one baboon gets into a
fight with another, his ally
will intervene and help him.
So these alliances
can be long-term.
They're cooperative
relationships.
And every now and then, the two
baboons need to figure out
whether the other male is
still committed to the
relationship, whether they
can be trusted or not.
So what they do to check the
commitment is they get
together and they fondle
each other's genitalia.
They briefly handle the other
baboon's testicles.
It turns out that the word
"testify" comes from the Latin
word "testes," which means
"testicle," because in ancient
Rome, two men who made a pledge
of allegiance would
hold each other's testicles.
And a man would hold his
own testicles while
testifying in court.
And that's where the
word comes from.
So why do the baboons do
this and why do the
ancient Romans do this?
Well, the idea is that if
you're in a cooperative
relationship, you need to test
the strength of the other
person's commitment.
And there's weak ways and
strong ways to do this.
If you're in a romantic
relationship, you can ask your
partner, do you still love me?
Are you sure you still
want to be with me?
And that can be a fine
way to test.
But sometimes people are not
good with words and they say
things they don't mean, or
sometimes they don't even know
what their real feelings are.
So research in biology suggests
that a stronger test
instead involves behaving in
ways that are risky, that are
dangerous, that are physically
intrusive--
essentially, in ways that raise
a cost of the other
individual.
And then you wait
for a reaction.
If the other individual is
willing to pay that cost, is
going to be patient and tolerate
your intrusion or
your annoying behavior, then it
means they're committed to
the relationship.
And you can have reason to relax
about the relationship.
If they're intolerant,
then it's bad news.
So the idea here is that the
best way to assess how much an
individual values your
relationship is to see what
kind of price they're
willing to pay.
It's a basic principle
from economics.
So that's called The
Handicap Principle.
And the person who advanced this
theory also argued that
it's not a coincidence, not an
accident that many expressions
of love and affection in
humans seem to have
stress-inducing elements.
If you think about it, why is
it that lovers, for example,
French kiss?
Why French kissing as opposed
to-- if you think about it,
it's a pretty intrusive,
invasive kind of thing.
You would agree to French kiss
somebody only if you really
love this person or you're
committed to the relationship.
And there's other elements--
he obviously has some ideas
about sex, also, being
intrusive and stressful.
And you might disagree
with that.
But the general idea is that
you impose a cost and see
whether the other individual is
willing to pay this cost.
So for the baboons, obviously,
having somebody come and touch
your testicles, very
risky business.
This baboon could put you out of
business in five seconds if
they have bad intentions.
And the baboon who does this
also is taking a big risk,
because you saw the size of the
canines of the baboons.
You could get bitten in the head
and be out of business.
So there's risk-taking
on both sides.
And there has to be a lot of
trust involved in this test of
this relationship.
So what biology and economics
tell us is that if you find
yourself in a long-term
cooperative relationship, you
must do all these things.
You must find out how your
partner behaved in previous
relationships--
so gather information about
previous behavior.
You have to monitor his or her
every move and play tit for
tat, like the prisoner's
dilemma.
You have to provide incentives
and rewards for cooperation as
well as discouragement and
punishment for cheating.
You have to use any means
at your disposal--
including feelings, morality,
religion, and the legal
system-- to make your
partner behave.
And finally, you have to check
the strength of his or her
commitment with bizarre, risky,
annoying, or sexually
daring behaviors on
a daily basis.
But the bad news is that,
despite all of these
precautions, a cooperative
relationship between two
individuals might
still go wrong.
And the simple reason for that
might be that you picked the
wrong person to begin with.
So how do you know if you picked
the right person or the
wrong person for you?
Well, typically, the way people
pick their partners
occurs in the context
of a market.
So we all operate in mating
markets, or marriage markets.
And the idea of the market is
that men and women have
different announcements that
members of the sex find more
or less appealing
or attractive.
In the case of men, women tend
to care about a slightly older
age, high physical
attractiveness, wealth, power,
high social celebrity status,
and so on and so forth.
Whereas men care about younger
age in women, physical
attractiveness, et cetera.
There's all kinds
of other things.
In a market, there's the laws
of supply and demand.
There are a few individuals that
have the endowments that
make them appealing, and
many others who don't.
So there's people like Angelina
Jolie and George
Clooney who are in very high
demand-- everybody wants
people like that as
their partners--
but in very low supply.
So the laws of the market are
such that individuals in that
situation can pretty much
pick and choose any
partner they want.
And they seem to do that.
So these are the partners
that they chose.
Although, I hear that George
Clooney has already moved on
and changed his mind,
and looking for
a new partner already.
And there's other ways in which
couples are matched for
endowments.
So this is an example of a
couple where individuals might
be matched in looks,
personality, social status.
That's another celebrity
couple.
I don't know how many of you
know Flavio Briatore, an
Italian Formula One
businessman.
The couple is matched because
even though he's not as
attractive as his wife,
he's got a lot of
money, celebrity status.
And so there's good matching.
And so the idea is that this
matching occurs in the market.
Whether or not people like it
or they want it, it's the
result of the market, the fact
that individuals differ in
these endowments, that there is
competition for people with
high endowments, and that there
is the laws of supply
and demand.
So good matching is a
good thing for you.
It makes couple more stable.
It makes it unlikely that the
relationship is associated
with different cost/benefit
ratios for the two partners,
and that might lead to one
partner to cheat or end the
relationship.
So how do you know where you
stand in the mating market,
what's your mate value is.
People pretty much figure out
the value of their endowments
with experience, with feedback
from other people,
particularly during adolescence,
and usually end
up pairing with an individual
who has similar value.
A human mating market is by no
means unique to our species.
There's mating markets
like this in birds,
other mammals, primates.
And they're not all about sex.
There are markets about other
things-- for example, in fish,
there is a species of large fish
that needs smaller fish
to swim inside their mouth and
clean their mouths from
parasites and other things.
These are called the cleaner
and the client.
So studies have shown that how
each fish chooses a partner
for this thing, it's a complex
operation that essentially
involves a market.
There are some cleaners, they
have very high endowments.
They have a good reputation.
They do a good job.
They don't cheat.
There are [INAUDIBLE]
instead who are nice, others
who end up swallowing the
little fish instead, so they
have a bad reputation.
So the way these fish pick and
choose one another, it's
really regulated by the
laws of the market.
So let me wrap this up now and
tell you why is it that we see
all these similarities between
humans and other species and
these games that we play.
There's two processes that
account for these
similarities.
One is called convergent
evolution, the idea that
organisms dealing with similar
social problems come up with
similar solutions
independently.
And I mentioned some of
these situations--
elevator effects,
market dynamics,
cooperation, nepotism.
The other phenomenon is called
phylogenetic inheritance, the
idea that two species that are
closely related might be
similar in their behavior
because they inherit these
behaviors from a common
ancestor.
So for example, chimpanzees and
humans are closely related.
We're very similar in some
behaviors because we inherited
these behaviors from an ancestor
that we share with
chimpanzees about 5 to
6 million years ago.
It's difficult to demonstrate
the inheritance of
behavior like this.
But they say a picture's worth a
thousand words, so here's my
contribution.
This shows that even the most
beautiful human smile has a
long evolutionary history.
That's a smile in a rhesus
monkey and a chimpanzee, and
that happens to be my wife.
Thanks for your attention.
And if you have any questions,
I'll be happy to
try to answer them.
AUDIENCE: I have one.
I have loads, actually.
But I'll try to stick to one.
I was interested in what you
said about dominance and
subordination.
And your explanation for
dominance is that it just
makes life easier in general--
faster and more efficient
things happen.
And then I was thinking about
how we're kind of product up
with values that tell us that,
well, democracy is right and
equality is right.
And you need to take in
everyone's views and then
figure out what's best
for everyone.
So that kind of seems completely
contrary to what
you've just said is kind of
the natural way, or the
biological inherited way.
So I'm just wondering what
your thoughts are.
DARIO MAESTRIPIERI: Well, I
guess I mentioned, I think
dominance is sort of an
intrinsic aspect of every
dyadic relationship.
Between two people, it's almost
inevitable that things
can't be exactly on a level
of balance and equality.
On a larger scale in a society,
obviously, there's
different degrees in terms of
how power is handled-- so
there's despotic systems, which,
obviously dominance is
right there in your face.
So there's despots who use and
abuse their power and systems
that are more egalitarian
and democratic.
But that doesn't mean that
in these egalitarian and
democratic systems there's
no dominance.
Obviously, there's people
with power and
people with less power.
And having or not having power
is associated with all kinds
of benefits and perks
and resources,
and things like that.
So it's really an inevitable--
I mean, communism tried to
eliminate distinctions of
power, and we know how
well that worked.
So I think it's better to
understand that the tendency
to be dominant is almost a
universal aspect of animal
behavior, including
human behavior.
Which doesn't make it
necessarily a good thing.
So it's not like, oh, it's
good to be dominant.
One thing that people can
realize is that if you happen
to be in a dominant position at
work or at home, dominance
comes with responsibility.
So the fact that you have the
potential to make decisions
means that you need to do it
nicely, in a way that takes
into account the needs and the
rights of other people.
So there is a sort of a gentle,
kinder aspect to
dominance which is an
opportunity if you happen to--
you also have an opportunity
to lead.
And if you have the ability
and the resources to lead,
then there's nothing wrong
with that, right?
AUDIENCE: Are you kind of
saying that despite our
highest ideals that we're kind
of programmed to fall into
those patterns of--?
DARIO MAESTRIPIERI: Well,
ask yourself.
Usually, say, if I ask you to
think about 100 different
relationships that you have with
people you know, starting
with your family members, your
friends, and ask you to think
whether you think you're
dominant or subordinate in
each one of these relationships,
my guess is
that you can give me
a good answer in at
least 95% of the cases.
I think if you think about it,
in 95% of your relationship,
you have a pretty good idea
whether you're the one who
calls the shots or
not so much.
There might be 5% where
things are unclear.
So does that mean dominance
is universal?
I think it's pretty
pervasive, yeah.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Can I just follow
on from that?
It seems to me there's another
big factor beyond dominance
and cooperation and negotiation
which also is
quite low cost, which is just
agreeing that you'll have
certain customs and patterns.
That's how my relationship
works with my wife.
There are lots of things that we
need to do which has a cost
to each of us, whoever
does it.
But we've just agreed that one
of us will do one, generally,
and the other will
do the other.
DARIO MAESTRIPIERI:
That's great.
There is division of labor and
there is ways to cooperate in
a way that is complementary.
But still, in every long-term
cooperative relationship,
there is always the potential
for disagreements.
No matter how good, how strong
your relationship is, you end
up disagreeing over a number of
small issues, big issues on
a daily basis.
And this is not just
in humans.
It happens in many species
of primates.
Aggression and fighting is most
common between closely
related individuals--
pairs of siblings, mothers and
daughters, males and females
who associate frequently.
They fight with each
other all the time.
The most frequent crimes are
committed in pairs of people
who know each other well.
So it's not that you go out
and kill strangers.
You go and kill your wife or
your child, stuff like that.
So your relationship can
be-- the point I'm
trying to make is--
I'm not trying to sell
some pessimistic
view of human nature.
But it's that its intrinsic to
the notion that if you're in a
long-term relationship with
somebody, there's many
opportunities for disagreeing
about the way you do things.
And fighting all the time, or
negotiating all the time,
every single time, it's
just not productive.
It's not cost effective.
It's stressful.
It's expensive energetically.
It might damage your
relationship.
It's not nice to negotiate
all the time.
Sometimes it's nice to make
a decision and go on.
And move on.
AUDIENCE: Actually, it's similar
to what you're saying.
Just thinking about lots of
different relationships, it
strikes me as the dominance
interplay actually varies
depending on what the topic
happens to be that they're
discussing.
So it's not like husband/wife,
employer/employee, the
dominant person's always the
same person throughout.
So I didn't see much
coming out--
DARIO MAESTRIPIERI: Dominance
is more complex than,
obviously, the way
I presented it.
So dominance, first of all,
is a characteristic of a
relationship, not a
characteristic of an
individual.
Which means that you can be
dominant in one relationship
but subordinate in another.
It depends on the relationship,
not on you.
But it's also that there are
individuals who tend to act
dominant, and to be dominant
in many relationships, and
others instead who are
dominant in very few
relationships.
In some cases, dominance is
independent of context, which
means that if you're dominant
in a relationship,
you call the shots.
You make decisions in every
single context.
In some cases, dominance is
context dependent, which means
that you make decisions about
one domain and the other
person makes the decisions
in another domain.
There's differences between
species and the extent to
which this happens.
In general, if there is a large
difference in dominance,
so if you're really of a
higher status than your
partner is, you tend
to make most
decisions across contests.
But it's sensitive to the
environment, to the
characteristic of the
other individual.
It's not a unitary concept.
It can be complex to explain.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Can we just
take two more questions?
Is that OK?
Because there's one
over there.
AUDIENCE: My question is, one
thing you started out with in
your lecture, or in your story
here, is basically that pretty
much everything humans do has a
at least rudimentary version
in the animal kingdom,
correct?
DARIO MAESTRIPIERI: In some
primate species, yes.
Not everything.
AUDIENCE: But then you go on
and you say, oh, but humans
are special.
And I don't get that.
Why are you suddenly-- are you
saying humans have a soul,
something that is not--
DARIO MAESTRIPIERI: OK,
so humans are special.
And every animal species
is special.
Your domestic cat is special.
They're not like dogs.
Dogs are special.
Chimpanzees are special.
Every species is special
in its own way.
Humans are special when compared
to other primates,
especially because we have
a very large brain.
So our large brain essentially
allows us to do things with
our minds that other animals
don't do, which is, for
example, produce abstract
thought.
We are unique in the animal
world in our ability to think
about things that don't exist in
reality, that exist only at
an abstract level.
Also, we're unique in our
ability to think about
religion, to think about God,
to think about spirituality,
to think about the future and
plan years in advance of
things that might happen, to
produce art, for example.
So there's all these ways-- and
to produce cultures and
laws and moralities, and
things like that.
I didn't say much about this
stuff because that's not what
my book is about.
My book is about social
relationships.
So the idea here is that despite
of these large brains,
and despite of this potential
that we have to think in
abstract ways-- to be moral, to
be artistic, intellectual--
when it comes to the day-to-day
problems of social
relationships, we end up using
solutions that have been
around a long time, that come
to us almost instinctively,
that our mind unconsciously
processes.
And so these solutions
are what we share
with these other animals.
So if I had written a book about
morality or God or art,
obviously I would have less of
a reason about primates.
But I do talk in one of
my chapters about--
because actually, somebody
yesterday asked me this
question, what about virtuous
people like artists or
religious leaders.
Can you compare those
to primates?
They've accomplished so much.
And the thing is that there's
always an interesting
disconnect between what these
people have accomplished in
their intellectual life, in
their public life, and what
they do in their
personal lives.
Sometimes talk about Pablo
Picasso and the issues he had
in his private life.
Sometimes you read about the
personal lives of these people
who were very virtuous in
public, but they have a
history of marriage and divorce,
of extramarital
affairs, of greed for money,
and things like that.
So when it comes to your
relationships and social
lives, I think people are much
much more similar to each
other than they are different
because we share this
background.
AUDIENCE: So when you gave a
comparison of communication
with another person over email
or in life, then one thing
came to my mind that with
internet and with email and
instant messaging, you can
actually allow yourself to
have conversations with several
different people.
And these conversations will be
unrelated from each other.
So does it somehow change
something in the patterns, or
are there new patterns
appearing?
DARIO MAESTRIPIERI: I'm
sure there are, yes.
I'm sure there's all kinds of
new things that originate with
the ability to interact
simultaneously
with multiple people.
But as there are benefits,
there's probably also costs.
So there's something that you
lose if you don't have that
direct, face-to-face
interactions.
When we speak in person, we use
facial expressions, we use
hand gestures to tell the other
person, look, what I'm
saying right now,
I mean it very
seriously or just for fun.
You can say, sometimes you
make me want to kill you.
But if I say it with
a smile on my face,
you know I'm joking.
If I say it on email,
you don't know what
to interpret that.
You have to use a little
emoticon with a little smiley
face to say I'm joking.
But do emoticons really
do it all?
Do they really replace all the
facial expressions, all the
other gestures that we use to
supplement the information
that we provide with
our words?
In my view, they don't.
And also, there's all kinds of
other dynamics that come into
play, including relative status,
costs and benefits,
what your expect from
the relationship.
That all plays a role in our
communication dynamics, no
matter how high tech they are.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm afraid that
we've run out of time.
But I just want to say thanks
again for coming in and
talking to us today.
DARIO MAESTRIPIERI: Thanks
for having me.
FEMALE SPEAKER: It's been a
really interesting talk.
And if you could just give him
another round of applause to
say thank you.